الامدادات العسكريه البريه لتدعيم هجمات
القوات الاوكرانيه قط ترافقها جوا طائرات
مقاتله وقنابل محظوره حيث تدور محادثات
حول نقل طرف ثالث لطائرات اف 16 اي اعاده
بعض الدول تصدير طائراتها الامريكيه
الاكياب للدفاع عن مجالها الجوي شركه
لوكيد مارتن المنتجه لهذا الطراز من
الطائرات ابدت استعدادها لتلبيه الطلب
وفقا لصحيفه فاينل اف 16 او الصقر المقاتل
طائره مقاتله نفاثه احاديه المحرك خفيفه
الوزن ومتعدده المهام ثم مات مشاهدينا
كطائره قنص خفيفه
وتطورت لمقاتله هجوميه دقيقه الاصابه
للاهداف ولديها طبعا قدره كبيره على
المناوره في الساحه تم انتاج حوالي
4,540 طائره اف 16 ولم تعد تشتريها القوات
الامريكيه لكن الانت مستمر لاغراض التصديق
مناقشات الاف 16 تتزامن مع اقتراح دوله
اوروبيه لم يكشف عن هويتها بعد ارسال
ذخائر عنقوديه لاوكرانيا هذه الذخائر
محرمه دوليا وفق معاهده امميه وقعتها معظم
الدول الغربيه باستثناء روسيا كما هو
معلوم فهي تنثر مشاهدينا عددا كبيرا من
القنابل الصغيره المتفجره وغالبا طبعا ما
تشكل تهديدا لفتره طويله حتى بعد انتهاء
الاذاعات لكن الدوله المجهوله حتى اللحظه
تشادل بان القنابل العنقضيه اسلحه مشروعه
فاضرار هذه القنابل الجلبيه جانبيه لم تعد
كبيره كما في السابق ويمكن التحكم بها
بشكل كبير وفقا تعبير هذه الدوله المجهوله
وللمفارقه بان شحنه القنابل العنقوديه هي
الاخرى بحاجه لضوء اخضر الماني لمشارتها
في الانتاج كما حصل مع دبابات